Ryan Reynolds has announced in true Ryan
Reynolds and Deadpool fashion that not
only is Deadpool coming to the MCU but
Deadpool 3 is going to be in phase 5
some of you may have caught Ryan
Reynolds's post to Instagram last night
a lot of you have been asking me many
questions about it there's a lot in it
and I'll go ahead and break everything
down about this post in this video and
exactly what he said including his
announcement of Deadpool 3 in phase 5
quick reminder I'm given my an Xbox one
or ps4 at the 500,000 subscriber mark
all you have to do to enter my giveaway
is be subscribed to my channel leave a
like and comment down below with your
favorite superhero or villain so as I
said last night Ryan Reynolds posted a
picture of a board and this board is him
trying to figure out who leaked footage
of Deadpool five years ago now a lot of
people have been asking me what this
means what everything on the board
really means well the board is really a
joke in itself the announcement of phase
5 isn't a joke but this is just a way to
kind of secretly announce Deadpool
coming to phase 5 because if you
remember Ryan Reynolds is actually the
person that leaked the footage five
years ago so this is just a long-running
joke at this point as you can see the
board really doesn't mean anything he's
got many different people on there he's
got Hugh Jackman who of course plays
Wolverine he's got Blake Lively who of
course is his wife he's got Betty White
he's got the original Wade Wilson from
the original Wolverine just kind of
everything related to Ryan Reynolds and
Deadpool so the board itself doesn't
really mean much it's more about what he
wrote to go along with the post that
really tells us about phase 5 the post
said investigation heading into year 5
or as I call it phase 5 the point is I
love conspiracy yarn hashtag leaked
adversary' so in this post Ryan Reynolds
literally just mentioned that Deadpool
is going to be in phase 5 and he did it
kind of secretly but also kind of
obviously again in true Ryan Reynolds
and Deadpool fashion he mentions phase 5
in the post but then immediately says
the point is I love conspiracy you are
trying to sidestep over the fact that he
didn't just say phase 5 but of course he
knows exactly what he's doing now this
doesn't really come as too much of a
surprise because we've heard recently
that Deadpool is going to be coming to
the MCU pretty soon david leitch the
director of the Deadpool movies did
that we can expect Deadpool three to
happen soon and then in an interview
with Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios directly after the comic-con
Hall H panel he was asked about Deadpool
because Deadpool was not mentioned in
the release in which Kevin Feige replied
I mentioned mutants and I considered
Deadpool a mutant so the fact that
Deadpool is coming to phase five is
actually really really big news for the
MCU because technically according to
Kevin Feige if the x-men don't get
introduced before Deadpool he is going
to be the first x-men introduced into
the MCU
and obviously this would open up a door
to introducing the other x-men to the
MCU as well and another thing is I know
that a lot of people have been asking
whether or not Deadpool is going to be
rated R or rated pg-13 now that it's
back at Disney well a lot of people are
saying that it is going to be pg-13
because it is Disney but let's not
forget about what the CEO of Disney Bob
Iger said about Deadpool coming back
over to Disney he did say that he is
open to doing rated-r movies and that
Deadpool could be a part of a mature set
of movies that Disney could do and let's
keep in mind blade is also coming as
well which could be rated R because the
original one was rated R so nothing is
confirmed but for those of you saying
that Deadpool is in fact going to be
pg-13 we don't necessarily know that yet
but thanks to Ryan Reynolds we do know
that Deadpool 3 is going to be a part of
phase 5 of the MCU so let me know how
excited you all are about Deadpool 3
coming to the MCU officially being part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and not
too long from now in Phase five again
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain liked this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 as well as some
other Marvel Legends items and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof